Welcome to the world of Squid Game.
We will now play six games with other participants.
Welcome to the Fortnite Squid Game.
You are all here because of declining Fortnite prize pools and views.
You chose to be here of your own free will unless eliminated.
We'll be playing six games.
Instructions on how each game works will be given at the start of each round.
Every time a player is eliminated,...
...five thousand V-Bucks will be added to the prize pool.
Here is the first game.
You will be playing "Red light, green light."
Now then, you are allowed to move forward when it shouts "Green light!"
Stop when it shouts "Red light!"
If your movement is detected afterwards, you will be eliminated.
The second game is sugar honeycombs.
The shape you have chosen is the shape you must remove from the honeycomb.
Use the pistol given to shoot the target displayed.
If you miss any targets, you will crack the honeycomb and be eliminated.